the rollout of the johnson and johnson
vaccine has been paused in the u.s
europe and south africa after reports of
rare blood clotting
in a very small number of people health
authorities said they were halting the
use of the shot while they investigate
the cases
and that they were doing this out of an
abundance of caution
the astrazeneca jab was also recently
temporarily suspended in some countries
after being linked to rare blood clots
authorities are calling it a short pause
the us's johnson johnson vaccine has hit
the same stumbling block as the uk's
astrazeneca jab did last month
a likely link to a rare and deadly blood
clot
use of johnson johnson's jansen vaccine
has now been halted across the u.s
with health authorities investigating
six incidents of clotting
in younger women one of them fatal
the u.s developed vaccine uses an
adenovirus to trigger immunity
the same mechanism as the astrazeneca
vaccine
jansen accounts for roughly five percent
of vaccines delivered so far in the us
so i had a j j vaccine appointment today
and i saw the news about it getting kind
of revoked
so i called and i asked and they said
you can get the pfizer vaccine instead
my wife just had a jnj with the vaccine
in like three days ago and so you know i
i'm just hoping that uh nothing
that is going to happen to her or you
know anybody who
got the job this is a setback to europe
too
johnson johnson announced it will delay
its rollout on the continent
the company had already started
processing an order from the eu
of 200 million doses
i imagine there will be repercussions as
we're waiting for millions of doses
but this means the controls are working
if we need to be cautious
we need to be cautious
the jansen jab has been partially rolled
out in africa where a majority of
countries don't have enough vaccines
even for their own health care workers
the african union signed a deal for 220
million doses this year
but u.s authorities remain hopeful
they're saying it could only be a matter
of days before the rollout resumes
let's get some more perspective on this
story with muhammad munir he's a
virologist
at lancaster university in the uk
mohammed it's good to have you back on
dw
do you think that it was the right
decision to pause the johnson johnson
vaccine rollout
uh well um assuming if we look on to the
number of vaccines that have been given
in the united states um
as the report indicated majority of them
being
uh by pfizer and madana and a very small
proportion five percent being through
johnson and johnson and this uh blood
clotting concern has not been uh
reported in the physical and modern
vaccine that have been rolled out for a
large scale so this means that there is
some serious concern that need to be
considered before continuing the rollout
so and then that is the medical
procedure where
any concerns are raised on a large scale
implication
pause the trial get a time enough to
validate the data and if there is any
link
then that is something that need to be
considered if no then we resume
okay so authorities are taking every
precaution here but what do you think
the delay of this rollout will mean for
vaccination efforts here in europe where
it's also been paused
i think it is certainly a setback
because not only in the european union
but also as you know in the south africa
they also
suspended their role out of this vaccine
and this vaccine has a certain unique
characteristics one
is that it's a single shot probably the
only single short vaccine that had been
approved
can be stored at refrigerated
temperature and many of the countries
were considering using the johnson
johnson as alternative to astrazeneca
and johnson johnson was probably one of
the few vaccines that have a proven
safety profile against south african
variant which is one of the most
uh transmissible pathogenic and can
escape the immunity
and above all my major concern is that
johnson johnson has been a big part of
the corvax facility
for the european effort for the low and
middle-income countries
so they have committed around 500
million doses for corvax
and if this path will continue or would
be a setback for this vaccine certainly
would be
a big damage to the vaccine rollout not
only in developing nation but also
in the developing nations you mentioned
that the astrazeneca as you said has
also been paused in several countries
what do you think this means for
vaccines like sputnik and some of the
vaccines from china
do you think that they are the next ones
which could that could also be stopped
because
they all belong to the same group of
viral vector vaccines the same type
absolutely this is very important
because if this link is
associated with the johnson johnson
regarding the blood clot
and the same as with the australzanica
that mean it is more associated with the
technology that is being used not
because of the vaccine
so this also means the sputnik v or the
cyano form
from the china and from the russia
respectively these are the ones that are
using the same technology those
also need to be considered onto the same
parameter
problem is that most of those vaccine
wherever those being deployed
we don't really have much data onto
sputnik v or the cyanoform
so if that data is transparently uh
digged into
i think that's going to give much more
clues that it is more associated with
the technology or it is
um overall the vaccine we'll have to
leave it there mohammed monir a
virologist at
lancaster university thank you so much
for your insights
thanks for having me
you